you play a character who i can't i mean
maybe i'm biased because i knew i was
going to talk to you today but for me it
was sort of a scene-stealing moment you
play a girl named amber who's quite
blunt uh a little bit chaotic uh yeah
and i know i have a few ambers in my
life do you have any amber's in your
life that you were able to draw some
inspiration from
you know i don't think i do i don't have
anyone in my life who's chaotic chaotic
i have like chaotic neutral you know
like
chaotic chaotic uh no amber is emery is
just a straight shoot
chaotic like
so fun to play so freeing just no filter
just
you know
takes it and runs kind of thing
um
how much of that process was because i
mean you're you are firing off changing
from inflection to inflection how much
of that was written in the script and
how much did you just get to kind of
have fun and play with that role and be
you know not the nicest person in the
world
well
todd wolf who directed and and wrote the
screenplay um
was like here like here is amber here is
who she is here her size here her lines
and like and then also do whatever you
want um so it was a really like
i don't know exciting creative and
healthy work environment and like really
really fun
um it was just really freeing
so
i i would say i would say mostly todd
but then also i
i don't know he might come to me and be
like no it was i'm not even sure what
was written in the script at this point
so
um you know for those for the
uninitiated jason maslow stars as uh and
a youtuber successful gamer uh who has
had a little bit of trouble managing his
work-life balance you know
yeah concerned about the state of his
relationship as a consequence um
i know work-life balance is something i
struggle with i i know a lot of people
these days do i'm gonna i'm gonna ask
you to sit in the psychologist chair a
little bit what's your secret to having
a healthy work-life balance
like i don't so
come on i guess therapy is a good tool
um
you know
checking in with yourself is a really
good tool
i think in my you know 20s i was going
to say early 20s but like most of my 20s
like probably until like i was 28 it was
a lot about speeding through things and
i only understood that after i was on
the other side of it a little bit and i
still do that i still think that that's
my
um disposition like i just want to like
keep going and like and rush things but
um
sort of that check-in process to
yourself because no one else is going to
do it for you so
you know having a having a place to
check in and what's really important for
me is having a creative outlet like
that's not work involved as well
so whatever that means and i think
a lot of people are like well i'm not a
creative person it's like everybody is a
create like has creativity every single
person you are a being of this earth you
have creativity find out what that like
bliss part is you know agreed i cannot
draw a straight line but this is my
creative outlet you know totally yeah uh
is the ukulele one of the creative
outlets
yeah it is one of them yeah this one's
not mine this one's my partner's but
yeah i always forget it's there
you know i gotta decorate this set a
little bit yeah um
amber and i don't want to get spoiled
too much but amber not the biggest fan
of the lead male in the film uh how do
you navigate a situation if you've ever
been there where you may not necessarily
like or gel with your friend's partner
yeah just like it hits like a little bit
hard um i've been there too by the way
i definitely don't do what amber does
which is just like let's burn you to the
ground and celebrate you know when
you're gonna get kicked to the curb
but you know once again it's sort of
that thing i mean like if the per you
don't know what someone else's
relationship is like from the inside and
if they're happy
then
whether or not you gel with their
partner isn't really up to you
and you can be their best friend too but
like you know someone always gives
something different than you can give
them
if it's like a problematic relationship
you know there's
i think that's a different story and
it's sort of
it's about knowing the person that is
your friend and hopefully knowing the
way that they will respond and hear you
because a lot of the time people
don't want to actually digest
you know things that might be good for
them myself included
um like a blind spot kind of thing
so
yeah i don't i don't know i think as
long as if they're happy and it's
healthy
then that's good
whether or not you gel with them or not
you know i love that okay well thank you
for sitting in the counselor's chair
this has been both productive and
honestly very helpful i think that's
some great advice um
you know you talked a little bit about
your creative outlets outside of work
but just sort of looking at your uh
let's put aside the nickelback music
video for one second let's look looking
at the last like 10 years or so a little
circle fact about it at the end
um it's been about 10 years that i saw
at least of like professional film and
tv credits and you've done so much
movies tv stage voice over i mean you're
on whose line is it uh you have kiss
kiss club the clothing line with the mix
and match outfits
what compels you to try your hand at so
many different things and you know this
is like a lifelong career for some
people entertainment it feels like
you've been able to pack so much into a
relatively short period of time
well thank you it's nice to hear it from
that point of view
um
i i don't i don't know it doesn't feel
like i think that i think the earlier
part especially working um on arrow and
across all those shows it it was it was
a lot packed in like that was like just
like a lot
um but in terms of
you know other sort of creative outlets
and like where those have gone
throughout like 10 years is especially
in your 20s is like a really like
formative 10 years and things change and
i think as things change as long as
you're open to them you you will go into
other facets and it doesn't seem as many
as packed in
as you're like taste testing or trying
you know trying other things and and
seeing what hits and
um
i mean
stage at acting as i was lucky enough to
like know that was always what i wanted
to do and that is always like just sunk
in really deeply but you know trying
trying stuff up with like you know kiss
x and like doing more stuff of that is
like more just like trying
that creative outlet and it's really fun
and
um
a lot of writing and voice over is great
but yeah it's kind of like feeling like
what level do those things sink in for
your being at and then
um
you know you got a long life and a short
one
i i've noticed the theme a couple times
of you mentioning sort of the sprint
that was sort of the launch of your
career especially with arrow and what
came after i noticed obviously you've
got um this movie coming out we need to
talk but it was filmed a couple years
ago it's been doing the festival circuit
um
is there a reason to be willing to share
about why maybe i haven't seen as much
on your credit line in the last two
years
yeah so after
after i did we need to talk i went to
new york and i did an off-broadway show
there and after that i decided to take
some time off i wanted to write and
um spend time with my family
because even though i was working at
home i
during those like eight years i wasn't
seeing my family like a whole lot and i
didn't realize that until it was all
over um
you know and and some like really
important family members had passed away
and and some
you know some like big life-changing
moments that happened that i just wasn't
really present for and that
that became like a very important
um notice for me
and i think i needed time to sort of be
be
um without any input for create like
creatively like i came home after new
york and i kind of just sat there like
catatonic for a little bit and then just
sort of digested and metabolized what
had happened
um
for you know the better part of my 20s
and
now there's some fresh air around and
it's nice
thank you for sharing and
summer's coming up a lot of camping and
store i hope oh yeah around the bc area
so oh yeah that's amazing and that's
really important thing to hear i think
how many times do you hear people say at
the end of their life i wish i didn't
work so much you know so i think it's
amazing to take some time off and i
commend you for that because i think
it's hard for a lot of people to do
especially when it feels like they've
got momentum behind them
yeah i mean it
i don't know how much like a lot like
some of it was forced and some of it
like becomes the thing that you think
you've chosen like i think that that's
life too like you kind of you kind of
were there and then you're like oh like
i like you get i get the jitters being
like oh i want to be working and then
it's like oh i chose this like what
where like where is that
uncomfortability and sort of learning
what that uncomfortability is and how
how i personally at least deal with it
has been a very interesting revelation
for my
getting to know myself
okay the best journey is the journey of
self right there you go um obviously you
know a lot of people came to uh be
familiar with you through arrow felicity
smoke it was supposed to be kind of a
one-off appearance and from what i
understand and everything just drilled
so well and everyone involved was so
happy with it that you end up becoming a
very integral part of that show i read
that stephen ml shout out to our fellow
canadians is one of the people who who
sort of advocated to have felicity
reappear do you remember anything from
that time in regards to stephen sort of
pushing or advocating for more of you in
that show
yeah i mean i i stephen always had my
back and um
in like
you know more ways than one we were a
great team for so long and um
yeah i i think like a lot of people
didn't really know what to do with me to
be honest like i didn't even know like
you know you're writing a show you're
the third episode of a brand new show
you you hope it goes a long time and we
went you know eight season but the
reality of it is like most shows go a
season
and so you just you just don't know like
um
you know it's sort of like build that
like you're building the story and i
think that's the best part of writing
and creating something um
you know especially especially like greg
who's who is our show runner and creator
like like really building and a world
and so it's finding those places that
people fit in and i i don't know i'd
have to ask him like did you see eight
like eight separate shows going all at
once like did you see that or did you
want to start
like and it kind of just goes along
right like a little
like a russian doll
it's cute
it's honestly mind-blowing like to be
able to
manage all that at scale i can hardly
manage having more than one appointment
or meeting in one day so shout out to
you for doing that yeah great
last thing on arrow before we finish on
some light stuff some fun stuff um
stephen amell recently stated about a
month ago that he'd actually be
interested in doing a ninth season
either a limited run or a full run um
maybe some more blood in there he said i
think he wants to mature a little bit uh
would you have any interest in returning
should there be a nine season and i know
you get asked that a lot but considering
his interest now does that change
anything i've actually never been asked
that oh no
but i was like i was a huge fan of
veronica mars like i
was a die-hard veronica mars fan i still
am i love kristen bell i think anything
she does i'd watch it
when the veronica mars like movie came
out and like fandom was like all about
it it's like a fan based movie like i
understand that and i understand like
working with people
um
that like you'd want to work with again
and also characters that you start
missing so
i don't know it would be it would be
interesting yeah i think i also think
like there's
there's opportunity for it
but maybe more time needs to pass like
there's something special about like
veronica mars coming back so late
like and i was older and i was just like
oh my goodness
oh my goodness you know
um like these characters still live on
and i think that's that's what's always
so interesting about like
film and tv you know that aren't based
on i shouldn't say real lives but you
know you know people who
who we know we're here and and um
but you you kind of only see like the
clips of the lives that
you know we the the team are showing
you or or get shown and
um it's like what happens in between all
those things so
let it breathe maybe maybe maybe have a
child and then you can take your kid to
sierra and then
um all right emily this has been amazing
so i'd love to end on some rapid fire
just some stuff a little off the beaten
path it's early but all right
what are some must-have items or
activities for the killer camping trip
oh
must-have activities right like anything
like paddle boarding dogs
um burgers you know just like a part
like we have like little tiny barbecues
but like is it a camping trip where we
sit and we can't or is it coming true
where we like hike with our backpack
what's your preference
probably the hiking with the backpacks
um
i'm a matcha drinker and you can't drink
matcha without a whisk and so i bring a
tiny whisk with me and i get made fun of
because everyone else drinks like
instant coffee but you can't make
history so i come around my little whisk
everywhere i go and that's my that's my
luxury item you're only allowed one so
one lecture and i'm like well you know
you're in the woods you're supposed to
try and make it feel a little yeah
yeah
rate your surfing skills on a scale of
one to ten
six
yeah it's not gonna get as much
confidence it's not good like we also we
learned to surf here in tofino which is
just like it's just about getting hit
with whitewash waves until you can get
out there and
my partner's got extremely long arms and
like grew up surfing and like getting
past that
break is like incredibly easy and and
i'll go out with you know and and like
women my size can do it too who are much
more experienced but it's just like i'm
trying to like get out there and i'm
like oh
i come back in exhausted and ready for
beer so
beautiful uh how is your axe throw
i can't remember but i would imagine it
was amazing
i bet lots of experience you know
absolutely archery expo same thing uh
favorite jack box party pack game
i think is it called fibush yeah
yeah something like that but i know that
yeah that's not right is it called
fibish it's not it yeah it is
yeah
yeah right my favorite too all right
last one i i i warned you i set the tone
memories from the night 2009 nickelback
music video never going to be alone
but you were the star
um you played woman
according i did i played woman which i
still play
on a daily basis
um the audition process was
in a dark room with a casting director
who said okay stare at this x on the
wall i was like okay i got this
and she was like
now the x
disappears
and i was like and she's like and you're
sad about it but i was just like oh
i just like started becoming sad
i walked out and i was like
who knows you know it's a big audition
like i was like who knows maybe i got
him maybe i didn't
call my mom are you proud of me you know
it's a big deal
you nailed it
no better exterior in the game than
emily bedford yeah i mean you're looking
at it right now yes emily thank you so
much for doing this this has been
amazing if i got my info down right we
need to talk premieres on demand may
13th and preview fan premiere plus i
think a virtual screening on may 12th
yeah
amazing if there's anything you want to
let the people know about the movie
about your life anything else please
floor is yours
oh my goodness well the movie's super
fun i like i i hope to play amber or
amber adjacent again
let us know what you think
the team is awesome and we're excited to
see you
you